[Music]
19 states have suceeded the United
States Army ramps up activity the White
House issued warnings to the Western
forces as well as the Florida Alliance
the three term president assures the
uprising will be dealt with swiftly let
me know if you want to try anything off
are you guys aware there's like a pretty
huge civil war going on all across
America we just try to stay out with
what we see on the news seems like it's
for the
[Music]
best
citizens of America the so-called
Western forces of Texas and
California have suffered a very great
defeat at the hands of the United States
military Mr President do you regret the
use of air strikes against American
citizens we're moving to theca today we
need to go down there they shoot
journalists alls side in the capital
every Instinct in and he says this is
death
what every time I survived the war zone
I thought I was sending a warning home
don't do
that but here we are there's some kind
of misunderstanding
here we American
okay okay what kind of American are
you you don't
know
the Western forces will reach the White
House on July 4th oh my god get in the
get in
the move move
move you're going to hang back I'm not
hanging back one
nation under God
indivisible with
liberty and justice for all
go go go go
go God Bless
[Applause]
[Music]
America whatever you have to
do however long it takes
promise me you'll find your way
home
pself give me this
[Music]
promise
L and
gentl start your
engines
a
I'm furious up the darkest of
Angels the question
is do you have it in you to make it
Epic
when I
sleep I see strange
[Music]
things
memories not
Memories
new
things I see
everything that is
not
[Music]
everything
what a wonderful day
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm telling you it's going to be another
hot one out there in fact there are heat
alerts in effect for New Jersey feeling
like
[Music]
100° leaving me here on my
own what is
that
for the first time in New York history
people froze to death in the middle of
July what is it the death
chill the power to kill by fear
itself your veins turn to rivers of ice
your bones crack and the last thing you
see is your own tear Ducks freezing
up like literally scared to death so
[Music]
cool
fore
fore true
for
foree
foreign
[Music]
it's okay I'm here I'm here it's been a
while since you've had one of those
nightmares tell me what was it
about it's only
fragments nothing's
[Music]
clear you've been fighting the hinin for
decades
look
my family's been fighting them for
centuries your blood comes from Dukes
and great
houses here we're
equal what we do we do for the benefit
of
[Music]
all I'd very much like to be equal to
you maybe I'll show you the
way deal with this Prophet send s fade
rather he's
[Applause]
psychotic I see possible Futures all at
once and in so many Futures our enemies
Prevail but I do see a way there is a
narrow way
[Applause]
through
[Music]
my allegiance is to you you believe
me this is a form of power that our
world has not yet seen the ultimate of
[Music]
power I want you to know I will love you
as long as I
breathe you will never lose me as long
as you you stay who you are consider
what you're about to do for a trais
silence this prophecy is how they
enslave
us you are not prepared for what is to
come
for most of human
civilization we believed that life could
only
exist on the surface of our
planet
what else were we wrong
about welcome to my
world W you come on
in this world has more
secrets than we could possibly imagine
miracles I
get
still now and
[Music]
then what is
that that's not
Kong who could have done
this
Kong can't stop this on his
own he won't be
alone
welcome to my
world
is that a mini
Kong hey come on get your stuff let's
[Music]
go
let's try that H
[Music]
again a week ago I spent my life racing
against time I'm going to help you out
today okay trying to save people who are
running out of it get until one
moment changed
everything come on welcome back to the
land that we're
living I don't understand what's
happening I've been having
Vision I knew he was going to
die I think I'm seeing the
future New York City is a whole new
level of crazy these days what do you
want
me New York City is a whole new level of
crazy these days
this is an emergency get off the train
that man's trying to kill you why who
are you what is going
on I can see the
future oh what the hell she didn't see
that coming that's not how it
works I've seen that man before so who
is he Ezekiel Sims he was in the Amazon
with my mom when she was researching
spiders right before she
died wait I recognize you you live in my
building you're the paramedic yeah you
almost ran me
over you don't think this is weird how
we're all
connected it's honestly like the least
weird thing that's happened all
day
do you have no idea what those girls
have
[Applause]
come I think he can see into the
future he's trying to change what
happens do you get
down why aren you
why do you your future was almost so
different if you want to live you have
to trust
me get
ready
now you're showing off maybe a
little
[Applause]
my son never show
Mercy they are
pray we are
predators Bo your mother is
dead she died because she sent her away
she was weak sick in her mind you know
my business
yes power is about
strength if you show
weakness you will give our enemies an
opening Sho
shoot he's weak like his mother leave
him what happened that
day I stared death in the face and for
the first time I saw my true
self tell me about this
Hunter they say he uses a connection
with animals to track his
prey once you're on his
list there's only one way off there six
of us and only one of you there's six of
you now
[Music]
why do you hunt my father puts evil into
the
world I take it
[Music]
out think you have some kind of Honor
you were exactly like our father just
another man hunting for our
trophy we're
murderers isn't that what he taught us
you don't get to do that to me
anymore Mr
tlin Mr
tlin where's Mr tlin oh you're standing
in
him you're goddamn lunatic oh you just
figure that out
now
there is an animal inan ofas don't you
want to know why they call me the
Rhino wouldn't it be nice not to have to
lift the finger ever again because
everything is taken care of the dream is
now a reality welcome to the ultimate
personal assistant in your home we
guarantee he will change your life
forever hello I'm Tim your
technologically integrated manservant
how can I be of
service I think we're going to be really
happy here I love you for when the fully
integrated technology falls apart trust
me Abby you know exactly where you are
with a
robot I hope to bring you a life of ease
and pleasure if you'd kindly give me a
safe phrase I will be fully operational
safe phrase a series of four words that
will trigger an immediate shutdown to
ensure peace of
mind I'm not sure about that we said
things were going to be different here
what do you think you're perfect don't
you find them a bit freaky I think I
should very much like to be
loved you understand I've been
programmed to serve you over Paul I
don't like the way it looks out you you
deserve
better got you you freak
this was recorded when you went to
London with Mr
dcon trust is an admirable human quality
Abby do you know what's wrong with Abby
I'm afraid not Paul I'm not a person I'm
a
computer would you put it on for me
you's trying to break us up he's a
robot just stay away from
t
I won't let you do that again you cannot
be
[Music]
trusted I cannot allow you to shut me
down I do not wish to see you suffer I'm
sorry
Abby
[Music]
most of you are aware that you live in
reality parallel to many versions of
your Universe I've gathered you all to
save your
world that does not look good you got
that
right the threat is
real I was on one of the Earths that was
swallowed by this wave how well we have
here I come from a parallel Earth we
look down on super
villains welcome our newly formed team
of Heroes the Justice
League drained the power from
them thank you Justice
League something's about to happen
something
major I am Harbinger this is the thing
yeah I figured you each possess the
skills strength and speed to save your
Universe Great
Scott what's happening the universe it's
all Vanishing
look this is it I won't let you go is it
as bad as it looks yes 5 4 3 2
[Music]
1 hey everyone uh we're extremely sad to
have missed d23 but we've been working
very hard on the next Deadpool film for
uh a good long while now I've had to
really search my soul on this one uh his
first appearance in the MCU obviously
needs to feel special we need to stay
true to the character uh find new depth
new motivation new meaning every
Deadpool needs to stand out and stand
apart it's been an incredible challenge
that has forced me to reach down deep
inside and I
I have
nothing yeah just
completely empty up here and terrifying
but we did have one idea hey Hugh you
want to play Wolverine one more
time yeah sure
[Music]
R we always love
you I
will love
[Music]
[Applause]
you for centuries we have called out to
the
universe looking for
answers in 2024
the
universe
calls
back bring us your
[Music]
leader hi can you hear me honey now is a
really bad time okay bye I love you I
love you I love you love
you this is
new
no no no no no no no thank
[Music]
you wow please State the name of your
home world uh Earth welcome leader of
Earth we are the United Advan pces of
the Universe I think there's been a
mistake you're not the leader of all
Earth sorry for the mix up commence
memory WIP no
wait I am the leader of Earth why is
your voice different I I've always
talked like this since I was a kid which
I'm obviously not anymore but yes I run
the planet the trial of a Earth can
proceed uh-oh until then as you say on
Earth okay bye I love you okay I I love
I love
you
you're the talk of the communiverse if
Mom could see me now I know what you
mean I ate my mother at Birth but in
moments of great success I regret it
that's a thing for your species no just
a me thing everyone was
[Music]
shocked